hello everybody my name is markiplier
and these are my bros say hi bros yes
and we're here today to play a little
game yes and that game is called changed
yeah you've seen and go ahead you've
seen it you love it you know it you want
more of it here it is today change oh
[Music]
yes so you know how it works
Bob explain ours Oh each of us knows how
to word say the word change out loud and
it will start doing a scene with like
two of us and then a designated person
will be allowed to just be an [ __ ]
and when the [ __ ] says change the
last person speak has to change whatever
they said and then in an [ __ ] can
keep saying change until they're happy
yeah and then that's the reality it'll
make sense once we get started you are
too angry retail workers on Black Friday
kids keep messing up cheering the shelf
men if I get another kid who comes in
here and grabs every [ __ ] thing off
the shelf I'm gonna lose my goddamn mind
look we got to get through this we're
being paid 1.5 times pay which is
overtime we're thinking a lot what
one and a half times my normal pay us
still only like $14 an hour well I mean
you gotta think on the bright side I
change 14 I'm making 32 change oh no I
forgot to tell you only I'm making
double pay you're not the hell why that
was the only reason I agree to do this
you're the manager why don't why you
[ __ ] me well I mean I don't want to
literally bending me over this register
changed
you are literally ripping my pants off
change
you are literally delicately undoing my
belt like a ghost slide in my pants off
sensually you literally put your penis
into my butthole making you like doing
it now look you are gonna work today and
you're gonna do it for free because
you've been free
loading and been skipping out on me
because you've been sick so much for
free yeah for free you're at least gonna
pay me half of what I normally get okay
change
oh you tough negotiator I'll pay you to
be stuck stick cuz I told your wife I
have your pay somewhere on my body
and if you want to get paid you not only
have to find it but you have to find it
before the end of your shift
can I at least use my hands this time
time can I use anything that I want so
how deep inside of you is it let's be
real
oh man oh you trying to get an easy
answer out of me I'll give you a hint
it's in one of my buttholes what okay
look you'll get half your pay we'll
start you on health insurance next year
but you've got to get this line taken
care of these people are getting rowdy
listen to them
[Laughter]
so you're saying if I get rid of this
line of people like as quickly as
possible
yeah I get all those things you promise
yes all right all three
Oh Dan hey he's the music man all right
all right okay you know you are to salt
miners taking a break from your
back-breaking labors oh sure is hard
down in those salt mines nice break nice
up here though huh yeah that is this
hellscape of the alien world that we're
in mining salt for Earth millions of
miles away guess that's our lot in life
don't have to season our lunches though
that's nice yeah see what we got a bit
on salt salt everywhere that's true
that's cool how's the bones well I'm
gonna
open up mine here Oh yep it's ham and
cheese and alien bread change it's a
monster and roast beef and ale eh it's
Swiss chard and [ __ ]
yeah that's got a lot of it here
that's just what they have here on this
alien planet it's just rich and Richard
[ __ ] passable no yeah I see them
everywhere mmm popping around range just
rolling around range they don't move
it's laid around everywhere [ __ ] I'm
honestly curious how they got so evenly
distributed around the planet but yeah
don't don't question us or we'll kill
you you know in the regiment
you know there's their eyes talking
about having so many rectums and they're
concerned but we can't ask about it Plus
falling one around Oh who's talking
about it with this other management guy
so that they couldn't hear me Laurie and
everyone will appreciate it that whisper
one more time yeah right there it's kind
of arousing actually doing the salt mine
you know and we're like hey Jim I've
just down there like what makes it fun
you know that's your technique is I'm
more I'm more of like a like a I'm more
of like a whoa kind of a guy and it
hurts me when I do that was pretty clear
yeah
you know you don't want to try and break
up the salt with something change what
you don't want to try and pick up the
salt with that dick
and it was weird I thought it was weird
that the video phrase it like that but I
get it now because obviously some people
just feel a lot of emotion I do that but
just [ __ ] is it heavy or is it sharp
changing is it girthy or is it sort of
shabby
what attachments do you put on the end
of your penis
- mine - that's a good question bill
change that's a good question Henry
that's a good question I always wondered
where this name came from but to be
clear yeah it's pronounced what happened
oh
what you said is actually a swear word
on this planet management yes I'm just
gonna do a favor for you though you said
that boys turned you on - I thought I
was the only one do this thing we're
down there you know sometimes you need
to like clear some rubble and do what I
do as I taped my pickaxe and I rest it
right on the shaft shorten and then you
can sort of lean down and pretend like
you're doing something
basically [ __ ] your pick up your two
husbands in a store waiting for your
wives to finish shopping Tim I'm gonna
be real with you
my wife left me a week ago I just stand
here remembering the good old times of
waiting for to be done shopping Tim as
you know I know Tim I had no idea well
it's the truth just I miss her and I
don't know what else to do the only time
we ever spent together was never we were
out shopping and we're out shopping she
just left me standing in Walsh's shop so
I guess wouldn't listen which time
together at all you know I miss it so I
just stand here open another wife will
walk into my life one day and be that
cool shake my hand I'll say hey hey
shake mine maybe they will you know you
never hey don't don't you know don't get
your hopes up way too high we'll find
you another you know I'll be your
wingman what if we do that
yeah that's why should have plenty of
time while your wife's doing
I'm just a single woman shot excuse me
yes hello
are you in the market for a nice young
man are you in the market for it are you
looking for someone to really get you oh
yes absolutely my husband he wouldn't
wait for me
I've always wanted a man who would wait
well this man right here his name is Tim
uh he does so much waiting he'll wait
for years from you they call me a waiter
that's a serving kind of change they
call me sir weights a lot cuz I like to
wait good job I do wait I'm do nothing
but wait I just stand here all day
waiting wanting to find someone who will
make me wait well I'm almost convinced
but you know I've just been out of a
very troubling relationship and I don't
know if I'm ready to jump at in is there
something you could like do this'll
prove to me that you're you're you're
right
yes yes I have a little waiting dance I
like to do it's sharp oh it's getting
late Oh
times a-tickin better start sticking how
long time goes on but pants come off
anyway that is change thank you
everybody so much for watching you even
wait Thailand oh and special appearance
by Dan amusement hey if you enjoyed this
and want to see more improv self let us
know down in the comments below thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always what see you the next one bye
bye bye